what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
she-hulk episode 4 today john how are
you i'm so good coy jeandro how are you
friggin fantastic you better be koi
gendro guys check out some koi's comic
corner that's been on the channel has
been killing it lately also follow this
man on tick tock 30 second 15 second one
to three minute breakdowns
see strong hand gestures
[Laughter]
i like it
you haven't seen our episode three
reviews i haven't i i really am happy
for him you could have been over there
you gotta check it out i forgot to do
that
you know what the big hand clef he's the
zealous man this koi jondro um anyway
you guys uh forget hey what's the shirt
you got here greg that's a cool thing
that's a cool shirt greg well guess what
guys that is a real rejects exclusive
from shop zero edition dot com one of
our designs if you want to pick yourself
up a citizen kang shirt today go to shop
zero edition zeroaddition.com you'll
find it there and also leave a like
that's the main thing you got to do for
this video subscribe and click that
notification about to get notified when
our reaction for the next she-hulk is up
here on the channel as always full
interaction watch we see it with the
time code available at our patreon page
for super sexy rejects so much
i do point more than i realize because
whenever you do the thumbnails i'm like
i can point oh i must at least five
times very strong hand gestures we just
put it in that ai machine and you say
pointing and it knows
let's get to it
[Music]
the ancient art of
[Music]
[Music]
for my next illusion the great donnie
blaze oh [ __ ]
dammit
no jonathan's here oh donny
what is your name that is a troll and
you know
with two ends one y but it's not where
you think
wow
how about i try something
with a little more
heat
oh yeah oh dude did he steal that [ __ ]
[Music]
donny blaze
fyi these don't smell like anything
back that background ew
[Music]
isn't that donnie blaze guy the pervert
director from
rush entourage right he's going to make
it mean
oh
cut right magician sent you here
not exactly he sent me to a diff
dimension and a talking goat help me
escape a lava pit in exchange for six
drops of my blood
what
oh
this is the one where they kill adriana
it was so sad oh my god spoilers you
just ruined it
i cried for three days daddy is going to
pay for this
you and me messed up man
it's called people i've encouraged you
to watch the surprise
i guess you saw that wong is back
god everybody loves wong it's like
giving the show twitter armor for a week
[Music]
too many easter eggs you're going too
fast
all right we'll slow it down for you
okay good i thought like purple and
green
[Music]
that that's all it takes former student
of the mystic odds but he was kicked out
after a week when he summoned three kegs
and his former fraternity brother kai
dog to camotage
i need to make an example of tony blais
said a precedent that no unlicensed
persons ever attempt to practice the
mystic arts again damn
he's suing this is uh the american legal
system no judge is going to take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book oh book of a chanted no the book of
american
uh loss
do you want to leave your information
with me this time
surprised by how little wong knows yeah
if it's above all this white why hire a
lawyer
yeah
show me your matcher profile no
jennifer
oh my god we're not using your corporate
headshot as your profile photo she looks
good in it are you scared i'll become
more mystical than you
sorcerer supreme does an engaging
competition but i am more mystical in my
sleep
prove it
no no one is proving anything here is a
cease and desist cease and desist
what cease and desist
[Music]
someone's unmatcher
swipe right for a hot date
i would actually like to learn how to do
that
oh
couldn't just be a yes man to some stiff
boss you know
that's why i'm an entrepreneur oh in
what field tbd
uh i'm i'm a lawyer i i just started at
a firm downtown glk and h
have you heard of it
oh yeah i know downtown
smooth i'm a hulk
i can lift a full-size sedan with one
hand
okay
this has been so great yeah it really
has
[Music]
all right
thank you so much for the drinks yeah
for sure hey we should do this again
there's an idea
this is alan and she's like a six maybe
what oh my god wow alan she's gorgeous i
hate that guy he's the worst they cast
so well they're gonna crush him in the
post-credits scene
do you have any witnesses who can
corroborate your claim
no no no no no do you want to win this
or not yes we do your honor is that star
from lost boys
i'm going to show you my high school
dance routine
oh jeez bunyan please give us extra
mercy you can't bring that drink in here
oh you can finish it if you want i'm not
sick
and then he pushed me into a fire land
that must have been terrifying how did
you escape i made a pact with a demon
that i cannot discuss
this is very different because the
mystic arts is in fact real magic oh how
dare you real magic is this not real
magic your elegancy
[Music]
whatever man
you were supposed to be ghost rider
craig's upset
i object the man in the mortal realm has
the ability to cause a ripple so great
it reverberates through every dimension
and that ripple through galaxies has the
ability to destroy all life within the
known and unknown universe case closed
i have to agree with mr blaise he may
continue to practice his livelihood
you know i also
have a bird
that's two middle fingers longers can we
get froyo no we could talk about the
sopranos fine no more spoilers ugh
whatever i was over it after tony killed
christopher anyway
what i mean it was like a sunday i was
so sad
you're pissing me off lady
[Applause]
i'm not proud of this
those kinky guys get your kink on i mean
come on almost me
okay
she-hulk gonna smash respect how much
can you deadlift yep a literal tunnel i
just did 600. i'm not even a superhero
this guy's like buff jeffrey right
jeffrey
had a baby with mother's milk yeah
what about super speed night vision
impenetrable skin yeah my skin is
impenetrable at least with
anything on earth even vibranium
god you're just so powerful
what a specimen
did you just call me a specimen
as a compliment
is there anything worse than dating in
your 30s it's an insult to call women's
specimens i mean
it's the only word i use
here we are
i'm a pediatric oncologist
oh
can i be honest with you
i i've been on so many first dates and
i hate talking about myself tell me
about you clever move
should we split some fries
yeah let's get those to go
oh my god man
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
oh my
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
okay it's okay donnie blaze will handle
this
oh yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
close the fire hole
oh yeah
hell's breaking loose i can really use
your help just for the record i'm doing
this for the universe not for you right
perfect what should i do
call my lawyer
do you need to get that
it can wait
[Laughter]
i'll be right back
come on i feel like you're dead
[Laughter]
i'm not
my god it's constantine
[Music]
alley-oop
yes
hello fellas purple background um i was
wondering if you would agree to the
terms of our cease and desist
[Music]
my office will be in touch
[Music]
[Laughter]
my dudes is catching up wow
i love it
[Music]
gonna go bench press him who are you
uh
jen just
not in hulk form just jen
um cool i made breakfast yeah i'm gonna
go oh that breaks my heart
dick whatever hot doctor's a cliche
anyway
titania
if she's coming after me because of our
fight she's delusional no she's suing
you for misuse of a trademark
misuse of a trademark oh no she she's
got the name she's suing me over the
name she-hulk
but that's my name now that she
trademarked it first right oh is that
how it works your honor yeah get out of
here oh sorry thank you
kind of a bummer way to end this episode
i bet there's a fun tag
[Laughter]
man that doctor i don't get it man i did
both
both are attractive
both are awesome funny
good looking smart pistols the men in
this world suck toe the men in the
marvel cinematic universe are awful all
of them
tony cap
thor
cap weighted and and well i mean he's
the only
no he needed to learn how to improve
himself nope it's not the way it works
in christian america
this is a better world
i don't
want have you ever had uh tequila
sunrise no um i think so long island
iced tea yep
just vodka straight no i've had it uh
vodka and yak milk never again do you
have any of that here
uh actually we still have some left from
from the wedding i'd love to try some
yak milk wow what's your favorite drink
well
gin and tonic
wow
i don't know if you do bottomless gin
and tonic but we will find it okay oh my
god
[Laughter]
she's ghost rider
there you go that's the pack she made
actually kind of like that post credit
scene
i like that with the show it's week
tweaks you can't have everything be like
the big like i'm glad they're doing show
sized post credits you know what i mean
yeah
you also learned that
long knows how to drink
yay also in in real life uh
long benedict wong uh it brings up food
and interviews and stuff all the time so
i like that it's turned that into the
mcu so like drinks and food and like
that's so benedict wong and he's an
alcoholic in real life i mean there we
are
i said food i said sandwiches
and ice cream we talk about ice cream
and interviews a lot
benedict wong great man there goes koi
again plugging the fact that he's
interviewed benedict wong
interviews available on nerdist.com
you got any more things to plug
still got some time there's still three
credits
who else have you mentioned
corner check it out weekly who's another
unlikely friend of yours
that girl the drunk one you're the
casting department aren't you there is
no sarah holly's family it's just coy's
friends
i do love that uh rhys cuaro is cat
cuero's husband no really the director
of this show
no wonder the director of uh the
glorious i think she did seven of the
nine episodes and that's her husband i
bet she was trying to cast him to play
ghost right billy walsh
director of medellin
all right guys we got her to-do list up
here
we're to go through it
finalize blonsky injunction we saw that
happen at the bar something purple green
order highlights highlighters from oh
she's going to do highlighters in her
whole colors
that's clever
buy and read how to make friends and
influence people
do me both jen sign up for a big and
tall membership that's funny meeting
with holloway at 12 30.
plot points follow up with blonsky soul
mates call mom and dad regarding
birthday ideas pie the month club is
great order more chopsticks order those
cheetos you saw stop wasting choices
color code sticky notes drink more water
i have that on my tooth it's going too
fast
slow down and they topped out here how
many easter eggs come on come on okay
someone's got it like you zoom in and
enhance to be able to enhance get rid of
that's where all the johnny blaze easter
eggs are
all right 10 yeah meditation back to
research
precedence on likeness i p for miss pete
find direct contact information for one
he do one home cooked meal this week i
have that in mind too lee vs burn ooh
craft versus soul charles soul is one of
the big uh writers of she-hulk as are
liam burnley invented uh you know
obviously she'll and byrne is the most
iconic writer with the fourth wall
breaking like he introduced that and
then kraft is a recent writer soul is
the longest running current writer i
think his run just ended like four years
ago holy [ __ ] we finally got a real
easter egg uh jansen class action jansen
is a big inker as well of she-hulk so
all five of those names oh nice and feng
shui is an eastern technique of
arranging things in pleasing
orders to help you think better much
like the meditating and feel more serene
yeah obviously
all right
john and i just earned our place here
him with the overall broad strokes me
with five comic names
yes
job well done ladies and gentlemen why
we're here folks um i forgot to mention
coy's sitting on that side today it's
part of his punishment
you are you're in the john chair how do
you like it
how do you like being down on my level i
feel taller and mustache he uh he
he already saw
uh episode three and four but i may have
noticed i wasn't here last week cause i
was on probation and i was like now this
is your parole i was like yeah it
doesn't make sense for you to be with us
on episode three at all but i noticed
there weren't really spoilers like i
could like i was i behave i told you but
you know you had to find it for yourself
i know but at the same time i had to
honesty for the people that is the least
you could do is not spoil it but like
the people now you know how credible
greg's word is i wasn't here and then
this time i i reacted left so you
wouldn't see my reaction well i was like
well what's the least happy here because
you know
they only showed the press up to episode
four right so so i don't know what five
is and i don't know what to theorize
next which is honest yeah so there's no
point of you being here with the
theories
i was saying that there's nothing i know
that you don't know now we're on the
same page was my point oh you meant
theorize next from last week yeah
um all right well that's definitely star
from lost boys i love her that wasn't my
first judge yeah okay you ever seen lost
place no movie reaction incoming
uh so guys uh i think john i should give
our opinions first there
yeah i'm in the probation probation
secrets
cap
john take it away i i will say that i
was here for the fun of this episode it
definitely gave me
there are a couple things where yeah in
the greater scheme of the universe it's
a little maybe
wobbly in terms of exactly how to
consider all these characters when
they're in this universe versus when
they're everywhere else like i think
benedict wong does a really nice job of
bringing his commitment and intensity
while still complimenting sort of the
silliness that they're
kind of anybody who seems like they're
passing through this show is going to
have to deal with some silliness and i
feel like that's still kind of finding
its
feet a little bit but i overall enjoyed
again the kind of mad cappness and
the i thought the whole donnie blaze
story while not as satisfying as a
johnny blaze story was it was wacky and
uh
at least hearkened to more of the kinds
of situations we can see she-hulk having
to deal with even if him hiring her is a
little dubious at least at first but you
can see how in the courtroom they're
like okay it seems like we should maybe
have some kind of law preventing people
from just wantonly practicing
the mystic arts but uh but yeah what do
you think sir
well
i think
i think the first
half of this
i really liked the last half of this
episode a lot the last half really
worked for me uh i'm pretty much all
fronts like i i loved everything with
her dating as she-hulk i thought that
was a really nice thing to explore and
seeing how she i like the identity
struggle it creates for her like that to
me is like interesting character stuff
to deal with
of oh man she's being like
fetishized and
people are attracted to her based off of
something that she does not feel she
truly is like she's being propped up in
this thing that is ultimately it feels
like a guise for her in a lot of ways
and is not not the real her and she's
having a hard time being accepted and
she's so she's on this like weird kind
of interesting marvel journey of
acceptance of herself and i thought that
was really fun and the most engaging
part of it to me and then the donny
blaise stuff once the steak started to
kick in with the demons coming through
and then the way it was intersecting
with her dating life and then the action
that was there i thought that was really
enjoyable and that's when the donnie
blaze stuff started working for me i let
go of the whole like because
it was like a little bit after we did
that video a few weeks ago where was
like oh my god ghost because everyone
pitched it to us before i ever clicked
on that video everyone was like she's a
grocery cameo and then i have to go surf
like oh my god i just believed it was
and then people eventually pointed out
that that doesn't spell johnny to me and
i was like crap i got carried away yeah
um
so i got past that pretty fast
i did not really find that the that
interesting i had the same comp similar
complaint i thought they did it even
worse this time because i it wasn't
really like a major complaint of mine
last week this episode
actually feels like a complaint for me
is i'm not a fan of the way they've been
handling the courtroom scenes uh all
that much a lot of the times the
courtroom scenes are feeling like rushed
and kind of lacking some i want a little
bit of substance to them on a little bit
of like
just a tiny bit it's just some action is
the actual legality of this well
yeah that and then also some
some actual
i don't know if the right word is
suspense because it's not the right word
where you want to put the intent the
emotional intensity what i'm hoping
something's exciting about the courtroom
scene i'm hoping you're saving it for a
big long courtroom like i i think pacing
wise it's like throwaway throw away
longer like six episode courtroom thing
because i have the same problem like my
biggest issue is that
we talk about how it's courtroom show
until we're in the courtroom and then
it's like cut to the next thing and i
want to be in a courtroom show yeah it's
like rushing through it and it doesn't
feel at all like
a lived-in courtroom scene
yeah well i think yeah and the last
episode i thought did that too but this
one was distractingly not as like i
thought i was able to just kind of
forgive it easily in last week's episode
but in this one it's like ah come on
this the scenes is kind of not that
funny a little annoying
and a lot of flat jokes so i'll own and
and i the only thing i said to these
gents before we we started because i had
seen it uh is this was my least favorite
episode and that's tricky for me because
it was where we left off and the the
array of episodes so it's hard when
you're like i'm feeling it and then you
leave you're like but is that where
we're going and it was a weird spot to
kind of end on because they did show us
the first four and i was like oh no i
was like all about it when three ended
and then this one was like it kind of
left me like oh i wish i wish it had
either been three or five because i'm
hoping the next one kind of gets back on
track this one did feel not like a
filler but it it didn't feel like it had
any sort of like landing to me yeah
what's funny is i would say the last
half of this i like more than episode
three
but in terms of the whole episode it
probably is my least favorite and it's
not like we have to rank everything but
when you see it as a chunk like i did
you feel that like when you walk out
feeling like when you watch a movie and
the third act doesn't land like the
first two you feel it so for me this
episode and like i don't know if it's
because you know we're about to get
giant things in the fifth episode they
didn't want like the press to know i
don't know if it's we're about to go on
that longer courtroom thing that i think
we are maybe starting with the next
episode it does just feel like we're
we're
as it ends um
yeah i mean like it just i didn't feel
anything i wanted to feel yeah are you
excited for next week with the t
to t to tania
you want to go on the catwalk the cat
walk peter
yo you went
you zigged and i sacked i was like you
sound just like that scene in wonderland
[Music]
uh
always
yeah
a little more titania i like the uh i
mean at least right now i don't know
exactly what her full-on presence is
going to be like but i like the way
they've been building her up in the
background and yeah that's kind of a fun
clever bit of her
opportunistically trademarking the name
just to create trouble and probably make
a quick book
uh and yeah like i like that as a legal
hook to get us into the next episode and
that seems like a a personal issue that
would take you know some argument and
also we might find jen in a position to
need her own lawyer i'm excited
i'm also excited for super influencer
because they've done a pretty good job
with you know uh acknowledging fans
being like we need a twitter guard for
the weeks we have long like they're very
good they're very good at playing
defense while making jokes at it like
the fourth wall breaking here is so good
to me because it doesn't feel like
deadpool in that it is
uh
part of your experience but it does feel
like part of the show's experience and
that's hard to quantify when i watch
deadpool or read deadpool i feel like
i'm a character in
the deadpool experience whereas in
shield i feel like i'm an audience
member and then that's a really like
interesting line to walk and i love that
they've managed to do that because
that's how the comics feel john burn
comics a lot of the covers are literally
acknowledging you the reader but it's
not like you the reader are in
she-hulk's world and likewise the show
is nailing that so i'm excited for one
deadpool obviously spoiler my guy but
two i'm excited for the influencer
element to also tie into our world
because half of marvel's press is us
being excited about things so i'm really
curious how they look at that in a meta
lens that still is removed that's still
a commentary on without being meta
modernistic where it ties you
intrinsically to the experience
yeah that's a good point that was that
was a thick old thought slice there dude
that was cute
but i do feel like like the the
beautiful thing about like the the era
we're living in with metamodernism is
it's that sincere irony right it's that
it's that wink and a tear and what
they're doing here is they're setting up
for that option of you as the observer
to feel like you're just voyeuristic
enough you're just purveying enough to
feel like this is a universe you're
watching but not intrinsically again
involved with and how does that work
when we are literally doing the thing
we're about to meet a character doing
how does that work when the world does
start to involve laws that will affect
the greater mcu going forward so this is
a great character to start to bridge
that gap where i think deadpool's going
to go and where i think they need to go
as the universe expands out there needs
to be repercussions there need to be
laws because i do think we're getting
dodc being a big factor i do think
thunderbolts are going to be a big
factor and they need to make sure we
feel like we're invested in the law side
because we're the ones that observed it
in a very first-person way through
she-hulk like we're gonna see precedents
be established in the show that'll
affect the greater mcu so we need to
feel like we were in that courtroom and
i think that's what titania is going to
be i hope so because they did establish
the superhuman law division and it
doesn't doesn't it just so it keeps
feeling like bits to me
versus something that feels like a
substantial thing or a movement with
government and agency and all that it
just it's just kind of
i'm hoping random kooky bits yeah you
only ever see her in her office with
nikki or or in like the the deciding
moments of a particular day in court but
it's like court cases are about breaking
down and sifting through details and
there's detective work in that and i
feel like the same way people get so
gratified when like a batman character
gets taken out of just being gadgets and
punching and then also goes detective i
think we kind of need a similar thing
with jen like we hear how great of a
lawyer she is and she wants to be taken
seriously as a lawyer and i wish the
show would use that more as an asset
like you guys have said because the
rousing monologue the rousing you know
closing argument the heated back and
forth like those are things that you
want to really hunker down into when
you're in a court scene and not just
feel like oh every time we're back in
court it's a light bit and you're going
to have like a kooky lawyer to play off
of and uh you know brash uh you know
defendant or whatever who doesn't take
it seriously or at least exploring the
complexities that come into play with
infusing
this world of super humans with this old
form of u.s law system you know and i'm
like we're not really doing that it's
kind of like uh here here it just like
that point to kind of generic ass [ __ ]
instead of going like what is the real
problem to solve here and how do we how
do we start implementing some new laws
or something something along that path
that would be just so much more
interesting do you think how do we adapt
something
how do we adapt our laws in order to
accommodate the ever widening scope of
how reality works now yeah and that will
i hope this is not just blind optimism
but i do i think this is like when you
watch a rocky movie there's montage
montage montage and then you get the
final training thing that's more drawn
out in order to fight clubber lang like
i think we're going to get to the longer
courtroom that's going to establish the
third arc of the show next you know all
the all the black boxers were not all
clubber lang you know he's the one that
had the best montage though i think that
montage setting up because i just want
to make sure i just want to make sure
you don't think all of the black guys
were clubber language you know carl
weathers is in the mandalorian
club
guys disney pluses carl weathers is in
michael b jordan
but the montage is in the fourth one or
a montage on a montage which is like
breaking the fourth wall like she does
here because it's like 16 walls of
montage that said i think we're gonna
have a montage that land like these are
like vignettes i hope it's more like
establishing the tone of being in the
courtroom so then when it gets to long
prolonged things more
linear audiences aren't bored yeah i
think that's what they're doing i hope
that's what they're doing because i
don't think being a short-form comedy
absolves them from some of those legal
structures yeah like legal stories
linear audiences people that just want
hulk like linear audiences and someone
that wants like a procedurally show like
that's a compliment like what people
want and what we want can align yeah
yeah and i kind of craved a tad bit more
of at least emotional heft with the set
up leading into the dating side of it is
it sort of just i know it's just a
lifestyle thing it's part of just part
of people's life people date it's a
human thing everyone does it and they're
adult most people most animals in fact
most animals really have dating apps so
at that kind of felt a little like okay
i guess we're just doing this now as
opposed to kind of uh sitting with her
for a while of feeling like she needs to
go on a date or something like that or
that she does crave connection or
something they taste it with the
pressure from her friend but i would
have liked to like one more scene or
like you know her doing something by
herself and wanting someone there like
you know like maybe she's feeling the
loneliness or something of loneliness
that isn't or doesn't have to be
loneliness i don't want to say like
you're
like something to help support and a
little bit more of an emotional
investment into her dating life because
i like i think the main thing that they
have going that is strong
is everything when it does focus on more
of the personal mindset and and the
emotional stuff internally with jennifer
walters that is what i find is
consistently the most engaging for me
personally as a viewer
and then as koi hopes for more marvel
juices
give me easter eggs
i i actually really like from the cup of
march
reference squeeze that marvel
is that someone that ever wrote no i i
do think though that we we want every
actor that is so well cast in the show
to get more to chew on and i and i think
one thing i've been enjoying in the show
is much like emil blonsky which i was
excited for you guys to have seen now i
like the way they re uh configured him
where like i loved his modus operandi
and how that fits the narrative of both
the old hulk and the one now like it it
meshed whereas like
coy yes the motorcycle and i
the razon detroit
let me check my
my pocket watch here
who do you think you are me
the reasons behind his choices the
motivation his journey his his modus
operandi is his uh mos is the the the
juice the things that the man
juice the juice the juice
michael's secret juice guys the meals
juice is very important to me no but i
think that what they did really well
here is they have a tone in the show and
emil blonsky wouldn't have fit that tone
but you got these great actors that can
turn that performance to fit both
authentically to the email blondes we've
met and this world and i think with wong
what i want to see is more characters
that get to still feel authentic and
move the plot along as opposed to kind
of like the courtroom where it's bits
like i feel like wong got to be wong but
we also like it was serving the purpose
of a joke i would love to see the
purpose of drama and a joke much like
this is us referenced twice in the show
they use humor and drama to balance a
tone as opposed to this feel someone
like there's a drama scene there's a
joke scene yeah do what i mean i feel
like they kind of dumbed down wong a
little bit like you didn't be a little
bit aware of some of this
yeah a a court system you kind of got to
work through here unless i don't know
what wong's back he's done
for a long time maybe he's just he's
also been at the sanctuary
in new york
for a long time i like the whole idea of
him being oblivious to the law but i do
think it's a little weird for him to be
flummoxed at the idea that like the law
doesn't account for like half the stuff
that you guys do and you got to realize
like you know there is no legal
paperwork here you know especially as a
and that you would probably need that if
you're going to go to a court in america
especially as you know with what he does
as part of his lifestyle profession is
something that is so secretive
that he should know that perhaps trying
to apply the rules that he's laying down
to jen are not going to be the same i
don't know there were some times with
the talk there was like
one part of the joke of wong is that he
is speaking at a much more elevated
metaphysical level versus what the the
law system is and at times the jokes
were like okay i i get it but i've never
seen wong seem like this
i don't want to say
he's dumb but a little bit naive he's
savvier than that yeah and that's what i
think they nailed with blonski that
didn't quite work for me with wong
yeah
the rewriting of blonsky's journey made
sense it still worked for what his
perspective would be this one did feel
like a different take on a character and
that's what i'm curious about with like
charlie cox and like other people you
even said during the reaction like why
would he get a lawyer for this situation
well that's the thing is if they had
maybe
this is another thing where i feel like
i i liked a lot that we got here but i
feel like you could have split some of
this into multiple episodes or something
because i feel like it would have to be
like wong doesn't turn first to the
american legal system and she-hulk it's
like a resort he has to take because
other things aren't working for some
reason or he can't just kill this guy or
whatever so like i feel like they could
have done it but i feel like there is a
weird i like the size of these episodes
and i like the tone of
a half hour ostensible comedy but i do
think that they need to
maybe slow down and take a little more
time to set a few more things up because
also in the dating like i feel like this
could have felt like the episode where
she starts dating but it just feels like
one of the parts of this episode much
like wong coming in kind of blurs with
the last episode
and and yeah i don't know there's
there's something about it seems like he
just met her last time and has like that
most recent association and then is like
oh i have a conflict i guess i'm gonna
go see the last person i talked to yeah
just jennifer walters instead of making
it feel like a real choice you know you
do know jonathan majors is not played by
mr t right you know what's funny
jonathan majors is the villain of creed3
so it is
[Laughter]
guys it's all back to jonathan majors k
is in episode five we called it here
first oh man
um yeah well yeah this was fine it's fun
and um that girl's she's fun she's fun i
like her and mom yeah
she's she's at the next karaoke night
gin and tonics there is a very those la
girls do exist oh yeah
dating apps are as bad as that because
often those are on the other side of
them it's it's daunting and the sleazy
men that they portray in this show i was
so afraid that guy he was too interested
it was too good but only for one of
jen's nesses
yeah
wanna and i hope they continue to
discuss that because that's gotta be a
real thing like the second she she signs
up to she-hulk the whole time i was
wondering is this guy
does he actually care or is this just a
kink you know yeah
find you find yourself a man that loves
you as gin and shelky
i did both
that's the i feel like
i feel like most guys if you're
interested in she-hulk then you would be
psyched because it's kind of like you
get two people yeah at the same time
most guys would be like bro
i did she-hulk
and she-hulk is yeah they're both great
they're both lovely
um what do they ever do in the comics
where like they're different
personalities it's really a personality
because that's what separates her from
hulk is like you know you know you know
what i mean like sometimes in like like
like take like batman ego for example
sure where it's like oh you could hang
out with batman and bruce wayne like
this oh i see you're saying entities
yeah did you ever do something like that
where like the entities are divided i
think it's that they would lean more
hulk with that storyline just because
the safety of keeping them so different
i see what you're saying like there
could be a more like
sometimes they acknowledge that jen is
breaking the fourth wall in a way that
feels more she-hulk but like not in a
way that connects to a character in
comic because that kind of convolutes
where the wall is i'm just thinking
about like you know being able to date
both at the same time polyamorous really
yeah
is it if it's all the same consciousness
that's true with hulk you can definitely
date like five people at once that's
true a lot of voices in there a lot
going on especially in a mortal hulk
all right guys well that's it for today
um
am i the one who kind of liked this more
than
i think this is a lot of fun
i really like this the last half a lot
it was like it's kind of rare
it's easily the least smooth but it was
still really enjoyable and i did like
this i'm really glad to have seen it and
it was fun i'm just hoping things get a
little bit more cohesive for me in
episode five also really cool to see uh
billy walsh again i really like chris
quarrel that was fun yeah yeah yeah
it's fun all right well guys watch the
sopranos before this show ruins the
whole thing for you it's too late now
here we go
we're watching plenty more spoilers
watch this
nbc available on hulu the day after drop
shows incredible all right guys we'll
catch you soon oh yeah shop
zeroaddition.com get yourself a t-shirt
today kang next week
[Music]